oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve dans cette
grande interview un peu particulière
puisque nous l'avons réalisée en marge
du forum franco russe du développement
durable se tient ici à paris dans les
locaux de la représentation commerciale
de russie avec nous antoine perrut de
bonjour bonjour vous êtes cio comme on
dit dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales toi vous êtes plus pas
trop quoi de saint gobain russie ukraine
ne l'a pas depuis combien de temps je
suis revenu à deux réunions alors c'est
intéressant que que nous puissions vous
interrogez parce que vous êtes une
entreprise musila d apporter aux
multinationales parfois ces repas l'on
appelait la google de l'isolation ou de
ou de la construction s'était pas c'est
pas rien mais vous aviez déserté un
petit peu la russie pendant quatre ou
cinq ans je veux pas dire que vous
l'ayez boudé mais vous étiez détourné
moins d'investissements - d'activité et
puis avait pas de projet est là depuis
un an ça y est c'est reparti pourquoi
avez vous décidé et vous participez à
cette aventure de repartir enrichi
pourquoi le groupe qui dit que ce choix
oui on n'a pas boudé la russie
effectivement pendant cinq ans les
résultats ont été un peu plus faible
qu'avant en raison de la crise
économique qu'a subies la russie depuis
2015 bon suite à ça progressivement les
résultats se sont se sont améliorées et
ça nous permet aujourd'hui d'envisager
le futur de la russie beaucoup plus
sereinement et donc de revenir à des
niveaux d'investissement beaucoup plus
raisonnable les indicateurs sont bons
mois les indicateurs en ce moment où
semblent signaux que vous avez sur
l'activité oui oui le marché de la
construction se porte bien il ya eu un
grand derniers mois
besoin important il ya des besoins
importants il ya eu des mesures
d'incitation aussi l'an dernier du
gouvernement avec un taux réduit à 6%
donc tout ça fait que le aujourd'hui le
marché la construction se porte bien et
a des belles années devant lui alors
vous allez investir en production en
distribution aussi non introduction
voilà saint gobain en russie n'a que des
activités de production nous n'avons pas
d'activité de distribution contrairement
à d'autres pays donc on investit dans la
dans la production dans les usines avec
des nouvelles usines avec des
acquisitions d'entreprises au total vous
fait quoi quand d'investissement cib
centaines de millions d'euros ou alors à
peu près et ça représente quoi combien
d' usine ça alors on n'avait jamais vu
une dizaine ont maintenant on a une
dizaine on en avait sept l'an dernier et
on en a trois de plus déjà cette année
on a fait une acquisition au kazakhstan
on a fait une acquisition près de moscou
et on a juste lancé la production d'un
d'une usine dite greenfield c'est à dire
on part de rien d'un champ dans le sud
de la russie dont on a démarré il ya
rien à voir avec un projet dans les
années qui viennent de construire
combien de l'établissement industriel on
a deux autres projets en greenfield donc
en sibérie et en ukraine donc au total
on devrait arriver à à 12 plus les
potentielles acquisitions que nous
ferions d'ici là j'ai noté la ssii la
quasi brutalité avec laquelle non on ne
fait que de la production ça veut dire
qu'on ne va produire en russie non va
pas vendre en russie oui non pardon
jeudi ont fait que la production de
cette opposition
vous êtes qui tarde la wii est peut-être
effectivement non mais c'était en
opposition à la voilà la solution mais
bien évidemment on vend on vend nos
produits on a donc on a à peu près de
2000 personnes en russie on en a mille
deux cents qui travaille en usine on a
quatre cents 400 inscrits de vente
allant dans le jeu de la concurrence
mondiale il ya eu aussi le retour de
fabrication d'un certain nombre de pays
en développement vers des pays plus
matures comme l'europe occidentale est
ce qu'il ya dans le projet rapatriement
possible sous forme d'importation des
produits ce fait dans les usines
saint-gobain de russie non alors nous on
importe pas du tout où on va on n'est
pas qu'on va faire
nous on n'exporte pas du tout en europe
on exporte un petit peu de laine de
verre en ukraine mais parce qu'il ya pas
de production de laine de verre en
ukraine aujourd'hui mais on n'exporte
pas du tout en europe certains de nos
concurrents le fond les exportant en
pologne mais nous on exporte on
n'exporte pas du tout et d'ailleurs on
investit en europe de l'ouest on vient
d'annoncer saint gobain a annoncé la
création de la première usine qui
fabrique des plaques de plâtre zéro
carbone dans les nordiques on a annoncé
une nouvelle capacité en espagne de
plaques de plâtre également donc saint
gobain continue à investir en europe de
l'ouest et on on importe pas de produits
de russie en europe quelles sont les
conditions de production enrichi en
matière de coût par rapport à condition
qu'ils n'entament les coûts de
production sont effectivement plus
faible mais le marché est aussi plus
faible c'est aussi dû à une certaine
dévaluation du rouble qui fait que tous
les prix sont globalement plus faible à
la fois le prix de vente mais aussi des
coûts de production donc oui on est sur
des coûts de production globalement plus
faible énergie est plus faible à la main
d'oeuvre est plus faible en coups et pas
mal de matières premières locales sont
plus faibles après il ya une certaine
dose d'un port encore de matières
premières qui viennent contrebalancer ça
et qui rendent parfois certaines
situations locales un petit peu
difficile 100% sans tomber dans un débat
à la mode qui a allié à l'environnement
qui a lieu à l'environnement et à
l'écologie on a beaucoup dit que mon
l'ouest était écolo mais que l'est et
paul bert qu'est ce que vous faites
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour pour pour
respecter des critères et des canons qui
sont en vigueur en occident dans un pays
qui ne surveillent pas ou peut-être avec
moins d'intention ces facteurs d'art je
dirai pas qui ne surveillent pas
après effectivement c'est sûr que quand
le
le pib d'un pays dépendent
principalement des ressources
hydrocarbures on peut imaginer que la
motivation est plus faible mais on a
beaucoup de choses à faire en russie et
une conscience écologique qui apparaît
de plus en plus le président poutine a
dit cet été qu'il était temps d'agir on
voit que ils subissent aussi les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
peut être de manière plus intense avec
les feux de forêt en sibérie où
l'incident industrielle de norilsk l'été
dernier donc je pense qu'il ya une bonne
prise de conscience les jeunes
générations son ex et sans pression des
civils sahraouis dans nos équipes on a
beaucoup de gens qui viennent travailler
chez saint gobain grâce à notre
politique environnementale et qui nous
pousse qui nous pousse les jeunes qui
viennent nous voir en disant bah moi je
veux écrire le le rapport de du
développement durable pour la russie
voilà qui nous pousse à prendre des
mesures donc là la conscience écologique
aussi existe en russie et puis et puis
voilà moi je suis convaincu à titre
personnel que il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc qu observe aussi il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays en développement sur partout
partout et est ce que est ce qu'on fait
c'est pas parce qu'une tâche est
difficile qu'il faut pas la faire quel
est le différentiel de coût de revient
d'une usine d'écart données d'une usine
qu'il ne serait pas
alors vous avez construit des vignes
décarbonés vous on est en train de on
est alors qu'on y est on y travaille
c'est à dire carbone zéro ouais ouais en
béton oui alors c'est toujours pareil ça
dépend de ce qu'on compte c'est un des
point d'ailleurs de l'intervention
d'aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on pense
qu'est-ce qu'on compte dans la carbonite
dans la dans la neutralité carbone
il ya plusieurs niveaux d'émissions les
copains le scoop de the scope 3 le scope
3 cd émissions de nos clients à partir
des produits qu'on fabrique donc c'est
sûr que si on prend ça en compte c'est
un peu plus compliqué mais des mines et
des usines où on est mais rien du tout
comme carbone dans l' usine que ça soit
nos émissions directes ou alors des
émissions liées à la production
d'électricité nous en avons aujourd'hui
dans le monde en russie nous n'en avons
pas on est en train de travailler est-ce
que vous allez les usines qui sont en
trop soit appliqué ce genre protocole
oui on a une usine qui a déjà l'objectif
d'ici deux à trois ans d'être neutre en
carbone scoop 1 et deux en russie donc
donc oui c'est des sujets complètement
d'actualité qui sont tout à fait
possibles en russie et c'est une demande
expresse des autorités russes ou c'est
une initiative eci dans d'autres offres
c'est dans notre offre c'est une
initiative c'est une initiative saint
gobain quels sont les critères que vous
trouvé intéressant en investissant
russie et ceux qui le sont moins parce
que ça peut servir éventuellement de
pédagogie et de modèle pour des
investissements dans d'autres pays en
voie développement
est-ce que les cas de la main d'oeuvre
par exemple en russie et et correspond à
vos critères d'exigence oui alors je
réponds d'une certaine beijing enfin
louis simplet d'ingénieurs et la main
d'oeuvre très qualifiée et
on a vraiment pas de problème au niveau
de la qualité du
personnel employé chez saint gobain les
équipes sont vraiment de très bonne
qualité on peut avoir des problèmes de
recrutement et de fidélisation
en russie mais en tout cas la qualité de
la main d'oeuvre est vraiment très bonne
avec déjà ingénieurs qui sont vraiment
très très très très bon ce qui est
formidable en russie celle enthousiasme
des équipes la créativité des équipes
c'est ce sont des des gens qui sont
excessivement créatifs ils vont avoir
plein d'idées et ils vont les mettre en
place dans le digital ils sont
excessivement avancées dont on le voit
dans la vie de tous les jours et moi je
le vois aussi au travail la vitesse à
laquelle on a développé un site internet
où on va développer un calculateur pour
calculer l'impact énergétique de nos
solutions tout c'est toutes ces choses
là vont excessivement excessivement vite
en russie ça veut dire que cette usine
ligne que vous êtes en train de
construire
elles sont très digitalisées oui elles
sont elles sont rédigées utilisé mais
y'a pas que les usines qui sont des et
alizée on parle souvent effectivement de
l'industrie 4.0 pour la digitalisation
des usines mais ce qui est aussi
digitalisées c'est nos forces de vente
le suivi de nos de nos performances et
les relations avec avec les clients et
puis surtout on investit massivement
dans ce qu'on appelle le bim bim bim
modelling ligne formée shon modelling
c'est le bâtiment digital à la base
c'est la conception en trois dimensions
d'un bâtiment mais c'est pas que ça on
peut rajouter oui mais en fait ça dans
toutes les constructions du gie
maintenant donc à lens et surtout pour
tous les pour tous les bâtiments c'est
pas que pour la construction d'une usine
c'est vraiment nos solutions qu'on vend
pour construire un nouveau bâtiment
aujourd'hui les cabinets d'architectes
de plus en plus vont utiliser le bim
pour concevoir un bâtiment et vont
pouvoir simuler la performance
énergétique d'un bâtiment vont pouvoir
simuler son coût vont pouvoir et après
vont pouvoir appeler des modules on va
dire ben tiens je vais une cloison comme
ça à cet endroit là et ça va beaucoup
plus vite et le bim est une source de
développement futur considérables
notamment sur le bas carbone on va
pouvoir mettre les informations carbone
de chacun des matériaux du bâtiment et
obtenir immédiatement l'empreinte
carbone d'un nouveau bâtiment donc et ça
en russie le bim on est très avancé
antoine berry joey vous laisse repartir
merci si cet hiver maintenant nous a
conduits vers l'hiver de comment ça va
être la période la plus moins
confortable
vous riez mais c'est vrai c'est beaucoup
enfin vous savez des confrères que vous
avez qui travaillent au canada sont
aussi dans la nuit un peu dans la même
situation
on retrouve cette émission sur les
réseaux sociaux on retrouve en replay
sur sur l'antenne et puis et bien sûr
sur le site
internet rt france pointé
[Musique]